SO IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY
TO PROTECT PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES YOU MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERING HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING IF IT'S
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE OF THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS ARE NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE
ACCESSIBILITY TO PROCESS NOW WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE%
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL ONE
OF OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS. IS A
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY ARE THE
THAT IS SENATOR DOLLY PARTON
DOLLY. OUR CENTERS AS REMINDER
PLEASE MEET YOUR PHONES OR YOUR
COMPUTERS WILL GREATLY AID
ELIMINATE ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK
I ASK THAT EVERY TIME YOU WISH
TO BE RECOGNIZED YOU WERE USED
TO RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN
THE PROGRAM IF YOU ARE REMOTE.
OBVIOUSLY HERE I CAN SEE YOU.
EACH TIME YOU RECOGNIZE TO SPEAK
A POP UP WINDOW WILL ASK.
WHETHER YOU LIKE TO UNMUTE.
PLEASE LET ME BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING ARE I. T. PERSON I WILL
PUT YOU BACK ON YOU WHEN YOU ARE
DONE ONCE OR TWICE SPEAK PLEASE
MAKE SURE THAT YOU CAN BE SEEN%
ON THE SCREEN. STATE YOUR NAME
AND THEN YOUR THE- BE ABLE TO.
YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO HAVE PUBLIC ACCESS
WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC TO THE HEARING ROOM TO
THE SENATE SOCIAL DISTANCING
ALLOWS. I WILL BE USING
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHICH TESTIFIED
TODAY FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED
ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
844-291-6364 THE ACCESS CODE IS
THREE FIVE THREE ONE TWO EIGHT.
THREE FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE. AND OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR. TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION.
PRESS IS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THIS
COULD BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YU'LL
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
A MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DESTRUCTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE.
MEETING SERVICE OR HOW THEIR-
CONNECTIONS MUTED. ALL RIGHT. SO
WE GOT TWO ITEMS ON THE AGENDA
TODAY. ARE WE GOT ONE BILL SP
FORTY FIVE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON S. C. R. FIFTY
THREE. WHERE- LET'S WELL I GUESS
WITH THE CISCO LET'S LET THIS
WEEK WELL WE HAVE TO I GUESS
DOLLY IS NOT ABLE TO GIVE US A
QUORUM SO IF THE WEIGHT LEANING
IS ALSO ON OUR WAY SO IF WE WILL
BE. AT WILL HAVE A QUORUM
SHORTLY. ALL RIGHT SO WITH THAT
LET'S- LET'S NOW GO TO HEAR FROM
SENATOR MCGUIRE IF AT ALL
POSSIBLE. HE'S HERE TO PRESENT
S. S. C. R. FIFTY THREE AND- I
WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA PROCEED
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READY SENATOR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AT GOOD MORNING HAPPY NEW YEAR
TO YOU SIR HAPPY NEW YEAR TO
COMEDIAN YOU'RE INCREDIBLY
DEDICATED STAFF GRATEFUL TO BE
HERE AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ENGAGEMENT ON THIS RESOLUTION
I'LL BE VERY BRIEF S. C. R.
FIFTY THREE IS A CRITICAL
RESOLUTION. THAT DECLARES A
CLIMATE EMERGENCY THAT THREATENS
OUR STATE OUR NATION AND OUR
PLANET AS A WHOLE S. C. R. FIFTY
THREE PROCLAIMS THE GOLDEN
STATE'S COMMITMENT TO DOING
EVERYTHING IN ITS POWER TO
COMBAT THIS GROWING CRISIS THIS
IDEA OF DECLARING A CLIMATE
EMERGENCY HERE IN THE GOLDEN
STATE. WAS ORIGINALLY BROUGHT
FORWARD BY STUDENT CLIMATE
LEADERS AT CINEMA ACADEMY AND
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP THEIR TENACITY IN
THEIR FORWARD THINKING ON THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE. A NEW ANALYSIS
BY THE EUROPEAN UNION'S CLIMATE
CHANGE SERVICE WHICH TRACKS
GLOBAL TEMPERATURES AND OTHER
CLIMATE INDICATORS FOUND THAT
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WAS NE OF THE
WARMEST YEARS ON RECORD. EARTH'S
AVERAGE TEMPERATURE IS AROUND
ONE POINT ONE DEGRES CELSIUS
ABOVE AVERAGE PRE INDUSTRIAL
LEVELS WHICH I'M SURE YOU SAW
OVER THE WEEKEND WE ARE NOW
UNFORTUNATELY 73% OF THE WAY TO
THE ONE POINT 5 DEGREES
THRESHOLD SCIENTISTS WARNED.
THAT THE PLANET MY STAY UNDER TO
AVOID THE WORSTIMPACTS AND HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES EXTREME
HEAT IS NOW THE TOP WEATHER
RELATED KILLER IN THE UNITED
STATES. NOW CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE
IS ALWAYS BEEN VERY BOLD BUT THE
LAST COUPLE OF DECADES HAVE BEEN
THE HOTTEST ON RECORD HERE IN
THE GOLDEN STATE AND WE KNOW
THAT THIS CRISIS IS EVOLVING
FASTER THAN ANTICIPATED IN
COMMUNITIES BIG AND SMALL ARE
STARTING TO WITNESS. IT'S
DAMAGING IMPACTS GRATEFUL TO THE
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE THE
CHAIR NATURI SOURCES AS WELL AS
THE CHAIR BUDGETS HAVE TO FOR
THEIR INCREDIBLE WORK LAST YEAR
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED OVER
FIFTEEN BILLION ALONG WITH THE
GOVERNOR AND FUNDING. I HAD TO
TACKLE THE GROWING CLIMATE
WILDFIRE AND DROUGHT CRISIS AND
THAT'S SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH WELL IT
WAS THE MOST AGGRESSIVE CLIMATE
ACTION AGENDA IN THE COUNTRY WE
MUST DO MORE WOULD BE GRATEFUL
TO HAVE. YOUR SUPPORT- OF S. C.
R. FIFTY THREE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK
YOU SENATOR LET ME YET LET ME
JUST TAKE A QUICK MOMENT I
RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE. A QUORUM
SO LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HERE BATES DOLLY. HERE IN SOLACE. SKINNER STERN. WHITE HOUSE SKI
HERE. ALL RIGHT SO WE NOW HAVE A
QUORUM THAT'S FANTASTIC LET'S
NOW PROCEED WITH ANY GIVEN- SO
THERE'S NO WAY THAT YOU DO HAVE
WITNESSES HERE I HAVE A WITNESS
WAY WHEN THIS WERE REALLY
GRATEFUL BUT THE CLIMATE CENTER
IS WITH US TODAY VINCENT WILL BE
MAKING A VERY SHORT PRESENTATION
MISTER CHAIR ON BEHALF OF A
CRIME IT'S AN- INTERESTING. YOU
MAY PROCEED ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
MR CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON AND GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME MY NAME IS VINCENT RIGHT NOT
A GOVERNMENT THERE'S MANUAL WITH
CLIMATE CENTER AND A MODEST
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF ETHNIC
WITH THE THREE WHICH IS THE
CRITICAL RESOLUTION THAT
HIGHLIGHTS AND RECOGNIZES THE
URGENCY OF THE CLIMATE CRISIS
AND UNFOLDING ALL AROUND US. THE
KIND OF VENTURE THAT HAWKING ON
PROFIT WORKING FOR GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTIONS THAT SPEED NOT
SKIP A CREDIT THAT CALIFORNIA
CAMPAIGN WHICH AIMS TO
ACCELERATE THE DECLINE AT FALL
AND. JEANETTE NEGATIVE EMISSIONS
BY TWENTY THIRD. BUT HOW ABOUT
ON JAN AS WELL. BY DOCUMENT AND
WE- EXCELLED AND- DO YOU WANT
CAN GENERAL HAS ABOUT IT NOTHING
LESS THAN A COUNTRY. BOOKING
REFERRING TO YOU AND- THE
TECHNICAL SUPPORT. WHICH IS
BACKED BY TOP SCIENTISTS FROM
ACROSS THE WORLD. EXTREME EVENTS
WITNESSED OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
MONTHS I'M LITERALLY OFF THE
CHARTS. AND SOME ARE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE CLIMATE MODELS
THAT GUIDE GOVERNMENT DECISION
MAKING THAT. AND CAN HELP YOU
WITH YOUR- ALSO READ A LOT ABOUT
WITH YOUR TWENTY MEDICAL JOURNAL
ACROSS THE GLOBE DECLARING
SEPTEMBER THAT NO CLIMATE. WITH
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT THING. AND THAT
RAP- BURNING CLIMATE WITH THE
GREATEST. THE CLIMATE CRISIS
MANAGEMENT THAN CALIFORNIA WELL
WE HAVE BEEN SUBJECT RECORD
BREAKING WILDFIRES. EXTREME
WEALTH. AND REFLECTED THE
OUTAGES. IN THE EARLY STAGES OF
THE MOUTH OF THE CAVE OF DROUGHT
NEED TO BE ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE
IT HAS NEVER BEEN CLEAR THAT THE
TOPICS ANY KIND OF ACTION IS NOW
. I CALIFORNIA TAKEN. ONCE A-
AND FIGHT AGAIN THE CREDIT
CRISIS. WHAT KIND OF BILL THAT
MY GHG BY TARGETS ARE
COMMENSURATE WITH THE LATEST I'M
FINE AND RAPIDLY. DETERIORATING
CLIMATE REALITY DEMANDS. TO KNOW
HOW AND THE TECHNOLOGY STACK OF
BIRTH THE GREATEST CHALLENGE.
RIGHT THAT'S NOT ON OUR PLANET.
RIGHT PARKING AND MAKING
STRATEGIC. AND SHOW THE PATH TO
A NEW ZERO CARBON PROSPEROUS
EQUITABLE ECONOMY. ADVIL
CALIFORNIA THIRTY OF THE WORLD
THIS IS THE TIME TO DO MORE WITH
YOUR BIBLE THUMPING. THANK YOU
FOR ALL. RIGHT TIME RESOLUTIONS
THE STAGE FOR THIS CRITICAL
DISCUSSIONS IN THE TWENTY
TWENTIES SESSION. AND ACCORDING
TO WITH AND OF LEGISLATURES
TACKLED THE SECOND THREAT. THANK
YOU FOR TIME. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT I SO THAT'S OUR LEAD
SUPPORT WITNESS FOR THIS YEAR
FIFTY THREE- LET'S NOW SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN PERSON
WHO LIKE TO VOICE THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THE RESOLUTION. YOU MAY COME
TO THE MICROPHONE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBER MY NAME IS
ROUGH OKAY YOUNG YOUNG- SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF YOUR LOCAL TACKLE
ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
TRANSIT DIRECTOR AND A SHOWDOWN
WITH FORMER BERKELEY COUNCILMAN
AND CHAIR OF THE CLIMB NUMBER
SINGLE REVISION TASK FORCE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH APPRECIATE IT
. ALRIGHT LET'S NOW GO TO
WITNESSES WAITING JUSTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THAT ZERO AT
THIS TIME. YEAH. I CURRENTLY
HAVE ABOUT ARRIVING IN CUBA WILL
COLLIDE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HEY AM I AN ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY WITH- SENATOR ALAN AND
CHAIR MIKE AND CAROLYN MIKE
MCGUIRE I'M I'M TRYING TO SPEAK
ON- AT C. R. FIFTY THREE AND I'M
VERY AGAINST IT SO AM I RIGHT
PLEASE. WE'RE WE'RE GONNA TAKE
FOLKS WHO WANT TO SPEAK AGAINST
IT MAX ALL RIGHT NOW WE'RE
HEARING THAT THE PRO SIDE. BUT
IF YOU'D LIKE TO DO YOU WANT TO
JUST ARE. ARE YOU. I YEAH YOU'RE
AGAINST IT DO YOU DO YOU WANT IT
WE DON'T HAVE WE OPPOSITION IF
YOU WANT TO TAKE JUST A MINUTE
TO EXPRESS YOUR CONCERNS- BUT
WE'RE JUST GONNA GIVE ME ONE
MINUTE. WITH THEIR WILL. BE
GONE. ALL RIGHT- DONE I'D LIKE
TO SPEAK PLEASE. OKAY PLEASE GO
FOR YOUR- WE- WE DO NOT HAVE YOU
REGISTERED AS THE OPPOSITION BUT
WE DON'T HAVE A LEAD UP TO THIS
RESEARCH LET'S JUST GIVE YOU I
WILL GIVE YOU A MINUTE TO
EXPRESS YOUR CONCERNS. OKAY
NOBODY WANTS CLIMATE CHANGE BUT
IT'S ODD TO ME THAT YOU ABOUT
MAKERS BLAME EVERYTHING ON
CLIMATE CHANGE NEVER MIND THAT
YOUR FAILED WATER POLICY ALLOWED
COPPER WATER TO FLOW OUT TO THE
OCEAN NEVER MIND THAT THESE
PREVENTABLE GENOCIDAL FIRED KEEP
HAPPENING BECAUSE OF YOUR
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY WITH THE CPUC
AND PG&E NEVER MIND I LIVED IN
SENATOR MCGUIRE'S DISTRICT UNTIL
YOU PEOPLE BURNED IT DOWN YOU
BLAME EVERYTHING ON CLIMATE
CHANGE AND YOU TREAT YOUR
RESPONSIBILITY. WASTING. TIME
AND MONEY ON **** LIKE THAT.
LIKE YOU FOR THE- AND- SUCH A-
WIDE. THANK THE- YOU BLAME ON
QUITE CHANGE AND YOU KNOW. AND
CALLED ME TODAY AND HE GAVE IT
THE WAY WE KNOW WHAT PEOPLE ARE
DOING DOWN THERE AND WATCH THINK
OF IT I THANK YOU SO MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR PRINTER.
THANK YOU I WE'RE GONNA GO ON TO
THE NEXT. WINDOWS WERE TAKING
WHEN THIS ISN'T SUPPORT
WITNESSES. AT SUPPORT OF S. C.
R. FIFTY THREE. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AND OFFENDERS LUCAS FRERICHS ON
BEHALF OF THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF UNDER
REQUIRED AT THE R. FIFTY THREE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU BYE TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. JAMIE
MINOR ON BEHALF MARIN CLEAN
ENERGY- THE FIRST PPA IN THE
COURT OF LAW THANK YOU. I THINK
YOU'RE RIGHT EIGHTEEN FOR YOUR
CALL HAVE. ON BEHALF OF SAVE THE
REDWOODS LEAGUE IN FRONT OF THE
PORT OF FES FIFTY THREE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ALL
RIGHT THEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO AND WELCOME AND THEN WE
DID THE NEW WITH THREE FIFTY
HOBBLED WE STRONGLY SUPPORT. THE
ARTS FIFTY THREE. THANK YOU RYAN
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING AND- HAPPY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL AND
SUPPORTED THE PREMISE OF THIS
RESOLUTION INTEGRATION OF
SCIENCE. AND HIS COMMITTEE DOING
GREAT ALL THE SCIENCE INCLUDING
THE TECHNOLOGY NECESSARY TO MEET
THE CLIMATE CRISIS. THE RIGHT
MAN RECENTLY TOLD ME THE ONLY
PLACE CARBON CAPTURE IS
CONTROVERSIAL IN THE CALIFORNIA
CAPITAL. WORK TOGETHER TO
SUPPORT ALL THE SCIENCE. THAT
CLIMATE CRISIS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT YOU'RE RIGHT TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS CATHERINE BRANDENBURG
REPRESENTING THEM A CLEAN
PALETTE WITH APARTMENTS ABOVE A
FLAT FIFTY THREE THANK YOU. I
THINK YOU'RE RIGHT TWENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MANY OF MY DEALER
RIGHT TO THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE RESOLUTION CLIMATE CHANGE
EVENTS HAVE BECOME MORE FREQUENT
IN THE STATE AND IN THE US WE
ARE IN A CLIMATE EMERGENCY AND
IT IS IMPACTING HUMAN HEALTH BUT
THERE ARE YOU WITH ME. A
COLLEAGUE HAS ALWAYS BEEN AN
ISSUE IN CALIFORNIA AND OUR
PROGRESS IS INCREDIBLY
THREATENED TO CLIMATE CHANGE IN
FACT THE AMERICAN LUNG.
ASSOCIATION RIGHT I REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS IN THE IS INA-
TO TAKE EXPRESS YOUR SUPPORT.
BUT WE'RE NOT TAKE- SUBSET OF
TESTING I APOLOGIZE FOR WE
APPRECIATE YOUR- VOICING YOUR
SUPPORT NEXT CALL PLEASE. RIGHT
THE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS A LEASE
CONTRACT WITH CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS FORMALLY
YUP T. V. CALLING INSTRUCT THE
POINT WE APPRECIATE THE- BUYERS
LEADERSHIP ON THAT. THANK YOU.
YOU'RE RIGHT TWENTY SIXTH PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KALU THE
JUNIPER AND I'M- AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF STR FIFTY THREE
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE IT WAS CO
WRITTEN WITH HIGH SCHOOLERS-
EVEN WITH THE BLIND SPOT WHICH
IS REALLY IMPORTANT IN THIS
REMOTE COMMANDS A THIRD OF THE
REQUIRED- INCLUDING. IN THE
READING OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MY TWENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. RIGHT TWENTY FIVE. MY
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT
TAKE CARE. I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU. GREAT ARE
THERE NOW LET'S GO TO FOLKS WANT
TO VOICE CONCERNS I DON'T SEE
ANYONE HERE WAS IN ONE OF HIS
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL THIS
YEAR FIFTY THREE DOES ANYONE
HERE WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
WE DID GET WE GIVE ENTRY AN
OPPORTUNITY TO VOICE HER
CONCERNS THAT WILL TAKE THAT AS
THE LEAD WITNESS IN OPPOSITION-
ANYONE ELSE YOU'D LIKE TO WEIGH
IN IN OPPOSITION TO THIS AS HE
ARE FIFTY THREE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THE END OF
THE ROW AT THE TIME. I TRIED
LIKE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH. RIGHT CAN YOU PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR
ALLEN AND OTHERS SENATOR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- MY NAME IS
SURE NO WATCHING CALLING FOR
PARKER COUNTY MOMS. AND I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT WE HAVE THE SIX
MISSIONS IN THE WORLD THIS IS
NOT A CLIMATE EMERGENCY AND. I
OPPOSE THE R. FIFTY THREE. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU. YOUR AVAILABLE
BECAUSE MODERN. I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU. NO
THE COST OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU. OKAY I LET'S NOW OPEN THIS
UP TO DISCUSSION QUESTIONS
CONCERNS- THE GOOD TRIBUTE AS
UNDER SCANNER. THANK YOU CHAIR-
THANK YOU- CENTER MAGUIRE FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD- I WILL
MOVE IT. FIVE FOR A DISCUSSION
OF THAT I'M YOU KNOW WHAT SOME
PEOPLE MIGHT SAY WHY DO WE NEED
TO DECLARE AN EMERGENCY AND I
THINK THE ANALYSIS GIVES A GOOD.
EXAMPLE THAT WE HAVE NOT YET
DECLARED THIS AS AN EMERGENCY
WHILE WE REFERRED TO THE CLIMATE
CRISIS WE'VE NOT STATUTORILY OR
OTHERWISE DONE SO AND IT DOES
ENABLE CERTAIN ACTIONS THAT IN
QUICKER THAN- CAN BE NONE
OTHERWISE. AND I THINK AT THIS
POINT IN TIME IT IS ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT TO DO SO BECAUSE I THINK
FOR MANY OF US. IF WE TAKE IS
THIS THE KIND OF FUNNY ANALOGY
BUT IF WE TAKE WHAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW WITH THE PANDEMIC.
WE'VE GOT A GOOD PERCENT OF
PEOPLE EITHER VACCINATED OR
UNVACCINATED WHO FEEL LIKE OKAY
THE- YOU KNOW COVER IT'S GOING
TO BE PART OF US SO YOU KNOW I'M
DONE LIKE THIS WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO LIVE WITH IT. ENDEARS WITHOUT
THINKING ABOUT NECESSARILY
WEIGHING FULLY THE CONSEQUENCES
OF WHO IT MAY STILL REALLY HARM
AND I THINK FOR THE CLIMATE
CRISIS FOR MANY PEOPLE. WE'VE ME
WHILE THEY'RE STILL DENIERS
WE'VE BEEN IN THE MIDST OF IT
AND IT'S SO- REAL RIGHT NOW THAT
IT'S ALMOST LIKE WE'RE NEAR TO
IT. AND WE CAN'T AFFORD TO BE WE
CANNOT AFFORD TO BE- I MEAN I
FOUND MYSELF AS SOMEONE WHO
WORKED FOR SPECIALLY IN THIS
FIELD I WAS ONE OF THE EARLY
ACTORS IN THIS AREA STARTING
BACK IN NINETEEN NINETY. AND
I'VE GOTTEN TO THE POINT NOW
WHERE IT'S- FOR MANY YEARS AGO.
WAS THAT THIRTY SOME ODD YEARS.
YOU KNOW I CAN LIKE A YOU KNOW
WHAT. WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO MINUTE
SORRY PASSED. THAT WE CAN NOT WE
CANNOT INTERNALIZED DEFEAT ON.
WE STILL HAVE THE ABILITY TO
TURN IT AROUND BUT IT WOULD
REQUIRE THAT TYPE OF ACTION THAT
DECLARING IT AN EMERGENCY WOULD
TAKE. SO I WANT TO THANK SENATOR
MCGUIRE FOR DOING THAT I HOPE
THAT IT REALLY DOES- CAUSES TO
ACT IN THAT KIND OF EMERGENCY
WAY. AND WITH THAT WE'LL MOVE
IT. THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
. I VERY MUCH AGREE
THUNDERSTORMS- THANK YOU RICHARD
AND THANK YOU CENTER FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD INTO THE
COALITION BEHIND YOU'VE BEEN
RINGING THE ALARM FOR A WHILE
NOW- WE- WE WORKED ON SOME OF
THIS THIS SORT OF. EMERGENCY
DECLARATION CONCEPT DOWN IN LA-
THERE'S NOW AN OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY MOBILIZATION AND- I
WOULD LOVE TO ADD ON AND TRY TO
SUPPORT YOUR EFFORTS IN VEHICLE
OUT THERE IF THERE'S AN
APPROPRIATE TIME. I KNOW THE ONE
ISSUE THAT HAS COME UP AS THE-
AS THE LA AREA EMERGENCY
MOBILIZATION OFFICES STARTED
TAKING SHAPE- WHAT WE MEAN BY
EMERGENCY. YOU KNOW WHAT ONE
EMERGENCY TO US TO ANOTHER
PERSON CAN CAN BE LIKE THE
ALARMS GOING OFF BUT I CAN HIT
SNOOZE. OR OR MAYBE JUST DON'T
LISTEN TO THE ALARM GOING OFF
ANYMORE I MEAN I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S SOBERING COMMENTS FROM
SENATOR SKINNER ON THAT POINT-
OF HOW MUCH OF AN ALARM WE CAN
TAKE. I DO WONDER IN TERMS OF.
WHERE HOW TO ACTUALLY GET
SOMETHING OUT OF THIS RESOLUTION
TO FURTHER THE- URGENCY. I MEAN
WHEN YOU WHEN WE USE THE WORD
EMERGENCY IN THIS CASE DO YOU
THINK OF IT AS AN EMERGENCY LIKE
. OTHER EMERGENCIES AN
EARTHQUAKE OR WILDFIRE IN
PANDEMIC I MEAN WHEN WE'RE
DECLARING THAT EMERGENCY. SHOULD
SHOULD WE UNDERSTAND IN THOSE
SORT OF TERMS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER STERN- FOR THAT- IN THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND- SKINNER BOTH
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS CRITICAL
ISSUE SO NUMBER ONE I THINK IS
VERY SIMILAR TO- ANY OTHER TYPE
OF EMERGENCY I THINK THE BIGGEST
DIFFERENCES. THIS IS ONGOING.
IT'S GOING TO GET WORSE. AS BAD
AS OUR FIRES ARE- THEY
EVENTUALLY ARE ABLE TO PUT THAT
FIRE OUT FOR THAT COMMUNITY.
THIS IS ONGOING. AND THE ALARM
BELLS COULDN'T BE LOUDER. SO I
THINK THE STATE HAS ALREADY
STARTED THANKS TO YOUR
LEADERSHIP THINGS LEADERSHIP OF.
SARAH CASKEY IS WELL I PUT IN
FIFTEEN BILLION IN REGARDS TO
THAT RESPONSE TO THIS CRIME
EMERGENCY. BOTH ARE PREPARING
CAN COASTAL COMMUNITIES FOR
MANAGED ETREAT. FOR WILDFIRE
RESPONSE FOR REFORESTATION FOR
DROUGHT OUT FOR COOLING CENTERS
THE GOVERNOR'S GONNA PROPOSE OF
I BELIEVE ABOUT ANOTHER TWENTY
FIVE BILLION THIS YEAR. NOT FOR
THIS EMERGENCY THAT WE'RE FACING
RIGHT NOW- AND THIS IS GOING TO
HAVE TO BE ON GOING. SO I DO
AGREE THAT WE BECOME NUMB. THE
NEWS- AROUND THIS PLANET. HAS
NOT BEEN GOOD WHEN IT COMES TO
CLIMATE. AND WE'RE OVERWHELMED
WITH THE PANDEMIC. THAT MEANS WE
NEED TO REDOUBLE OUR EFFORTS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND BUILD
UPON THE SUCCESS THAT WE'VE HAD
LEADING THIS NATION. OUT OF THIS
EMERGENCY BOTH WITH MONEY IN
POLICYMAKERS ALSO I I'M GRATEFUL
TO OUR PROGRAM WHO IS NOW
LEADING OUR- KIND IT. ACTION
WORKING GROUP TO BE ABLE TO
BRING FORWARD POLICY SO I THINK
YOU'RE GONNA TWO PRONG APPROACH
THIS YEAR NUMBER ONE. BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS TO BE ABLE TO HELP
PREP COMMUNITIES INDOOR I HAVE
COMMUNITIES RESPOND TO THIS
EMERGENCY IN THE NUMBER TWO
LASTING POLICY THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO LEAD THE WAY HERE IN
NORTH AMERICA. WITH A CALIFORNIA
LEADERSHIP SO I THINK THAT'S A
BIT THAT IS THAT'S MY BELIEF IN
WOULD BE HONORED IF YOU'D BE
WILLING TO COME ON AS A CO
AUTHOR ON THIS PLEASE. YEP 1100%
COUNT ME IN AND I WOULD JUST SAY
AS YOU GO FORWARD SOMETHING TO
CONSIDER AND I DON'T. I DON'T
KNOW IF THIS GOES STRAIGHT TO
THE FLOOR WHAT BUT- THE I. D.
SURE THE JOINT EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE AND I'M
THINKING ABOUT THE EMERGENCY
SERVICES ACT AND ALL THE POWERS
THAT THAT ENTAILS AND I JUST. I
WONDER IF GOING FOR THAT
SOMETHING TO LOOK AT MAYBE NOT
IN THIS RESOLUTION BUT- HOW THAT
WOULD ACTUALLY. YOU KNOW IF YOU
WERE TO IF THE GOVERNOR WERE TO
DECLARE SUCH AN EMERGENCY-
INVOKING THOSE POWERS HOW WOULD
IT AFFECT IMPLEMENTATION SAY OF.
THE SCOPING PLANNER OF THE OTHER
AREAS OF LAW WE'VE GOT SO. MAYBE
NOT HERE BUT SOMETHING TO PONDER
ANYWAY THANK YOU FOR THE
CREATIVE AN IMPORTANT BILLING.
AT ALL- D'AGOSTINO SECOND THE
MOTION SO THINKING INTO THE
INNER WORLD ESSAYS THAT- THIS
WOULD PUT THE LEGISLATURE FIRMLY
ON RECORD IN REGARDS TO OUR
BELIEF THAT WE NEED TO BE
EMERGENCY- AND THE GOVERNOR
WOULD THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO
DECLARE ONE. THROUGH HIS
EXECUTIVE POWERS. YEAH SENECA.
YEAH I THINK PM THERE MAY BE AN
INTERESTED GOING. I AM LOOKING
AT THE NINETEEN SEVENTY
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY ACTIVITY TO
DETERMINE THE THRESHOLD. AS THE
STAFF REPORT CONCLUDES HERE IS
THAT. THE CLIMATE EMERGENCY
SEEMS TO BE JUSTIFIED BECAUSE-
FIFTY YEARS AGO WE ESTABLISHED.
CONDITIONS OF DISASTER OR
EXTREME PERIL TO THE SAFETY OF
PERSONS AND PROPERTY WITHIN THE
STATE CAUSED BY CONDITIONS AND
pTHEY SAY. YOUR POLLUTION FIRE
FLOOD STORM EPIDEMIC RIGHT
DROUGHT. K. CYBER TERRORISM
SUDDEN AND SEVERE ENERGY
SHORTAGE. PLANT OR ANIMAL
INFESTATION OR DISEASE SO WE
LAUGH AT HIM HERE AT THE BODY OF
LAW THAT WE'VE GOT NOW IF WE
WANT EXPANDED. BUT THAT SEEMS TO
BE YOU KNOW A LOT OF THOSE
CONDITIONS ARE GOING TO WORSEN
IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS AS A
STAFF REPORTER CUT BLOCKS OUT
SO- THAT'S- FOR THE- THE PUBLIC
SHOULD KNOW THAT IF WE LOOK AT
THAT WE THINK THAT WE NEED TO
EXPAND IT. THAT WOULD BE.
NATURAL RESOURCES TO DO THAT
BUT- I'D BE HONORED TO BE ADDED
ON A SET OF COLD WATER TO US AND
REQUIRED THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THE MATTER BEFORE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP CENTER CASKEY
THANK YOU SO MUCH. ALL RIGHT R.
LET'S GIVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CLOSE AT SEVEN EIGHT BAND. OF
TRYING HERE RIGHT. SEVEN I DON'T
HAVE THE RAISED A HAND. UP ON MY
SCREEN SO I TRIED WHAT I TEXTED
YOU OBVIOUSLY DID CATCH. YEAH
WELL M. AM I ABLE TO QUESTION
FOR IT TO ARRIVE I APOLOGIZE I.
DIDN'T SEE IT AREA I DON'T EVEN
SEE A TEXT OKAY. OF ART. WELL
FIRST OFF I JUST SAT SAY THAT TO
YOU KNOW I AGAIN AS GOOD TO BE-
ON THIS COMMITTEE AND- I LOOK
FORWARD TO TALKING ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE FACED WITH
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. OBVIOUSLY WE
HAVE THE DIXIE FIRE LAST YEAR
WHICH WAS. THE LARGEST SINGLE
FIRE- IT WAS ALL CONTAINED IN MY
DISTRICT. EXCEPT FOR A LITTLE
BIT OF TAME A COUNTY WHICH ALL-
PICK UP HERE NOW WITH
REDISTRICTING. BUT I'M VERY MUCH
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS RESOLUTION
IF WE YOU KNOW GOD HELP US IF WE
GET. ALL THE POWER TO THE
GOVERNOR TO. IMPLEMENT HOW WE'RE
GOING TO GO FORWARD WITH. INTEL
THE CLIMATE CHANGE THERE'S NO
DOUBT THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF
CHALLENGES IN CALIFORNIA BUT- I
JUST WANT TO SHARE THAT IT'S NOT
IT'S NOT ABOUT ARE WE LEAING
WE'RE WORSE I'VE BEEN ELECTED
NOW TWENTY FIVE YEARS. AND
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN TALKING ABOUT
LEADING AND CLIMATE CHANGE AND
IT'S THE IT'S THE WAY WE SPEND
THE MONEY IT'S THE POLICIES THAT
COME OUT OF LEGISLATURE THAT.
ARE VERY MUCH CONCERNING TO ME.
AS YOU ALL REMEMBER LAST YEAR I
BOUGHT A BILLBOARD IT CANNOT THE
CARBON. IS EMITTED IN FOREST
FIRES AND EVERY PERSON ON THIS
COMMITTEE. VOTED AGAINST IT I
DIDN'T GET I DID GET TO SENATOR
BASES. I VOTE- SO GOING FORWARD
IF WE'RE GONNA LEAD THE WORLD.
VIRTUALLY GOING TO LEAD THE
WORLD AND WE AND AS WE KNOW
CLIMATE IS. CHANGING AND IT'S
AND WE NEED TO HAVE THE CURB BUT
WE'RE DOING IT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AS WE'RE EXPORTING
JOBS. TO OTHER COUNTRIES THAT
POLLUTE MAINLY CHINA. AND WE'RE
WE FEEL GOOD ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE BUT WE'RE DRIVE I
THINK THE- THE LIVING UP. WE
SPENDING MONEY ON THINGS THAT WE
SHOULDN'T SPEND MONEY ON LIKE
THE BULLET TRAIN I BOUGHT UP
SEVERAL TIMES. SO IT'S NOT A
MATTER OF YOU KNOW PUTTING FEAR
THE PEOPLE THAT THIS IS AN
EMERGENCY ABSOLUTELY WE HAVE. A
LOT OF WORK TO DO BUT IT'S HOW
WE DO THE WORK. AND THE POLICIES
THAT COME BEHIND IT. THIS
STATEMENT BECAUSE THIS IS THE
RESOLUTION. BUT IF THE BILL CAME
FORWARD TO GIVE THE POWER TO THE
GOVERNOR. AND QUITE FRANKLY THE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN PUTTING
TOGETHER THIS CLIMATE ACTION
PLAN WHICH IS CAR WHICH WE GOT
AN AUDIT LAST YEAR SAYING THAT
DEBT REDUCTION OF CARBON REALLY
WASN'T COUNTED PROPERLY SO SOME
POLICIES AND I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT ARE GOING TO FOLLOW THIS
RESOLUTION. AND I'D LIKE TO
SENATOR TO EXPLAIN WHAT THE
FUTURE LOOKS LIKE IN CLIMATE
CHANGE ARE WE GONNA CONTINUE TO
REGULARLY- YOU KNOW SMALL
ENGINES WHEN WE WHEN WE DON'T
SPEND THE MONEY THAT WE SHOULD
ENFORCE TREE I LOOKED AT THE
BUDGET THAT WAS ROLLED OUT BY
THE GOVERNOR. AND THERE'S ONE
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS A
BILLION DOLLARS. FOR
FIREFIGHTING THAT'S FOR FIRE
SUPPRESSION IS OBVIOUSLY THE
BILL THAT THE- GOOD SENATOR.
MCGUIRE AND I ARE JOINING ALL
THREE FOUR. MORE FIREFIGHTERS
AND FIRE TRUCKS AND HELICOPTERS.
BUT WHAT IS OUR PLAN TO REALLY.
TACKLE THE BIG ISSUES LIKE.
DOING SOME FORESTRY PROJECTS AND
ACTUALLY GETTING THE MONEY OUT
LAST YEAR WE DID EARLY ACTION
PLAN. AND WE COULDN'T GET THE
MONEY ON THE GROUND SO I'D LIKE
TO KNOW WHAT FOLLOWS THIS. STATE
OF EMERGENCY BASICALLY WHAT THIS
BILL IS SAYING HEY THIS
EMERGENCY I THINK THE
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN MEETING I
THINK WE'VE BEEN SPENDING THE
MONEY IN THE WRONG PLACES I'D
LIKE TO KNOW WHAT THE FUTURE
LOOKS LIKE AS FAR AS LEGISLATION
FOLLOWING THIS. A RESOLUTION. I
WANT YOU I'M DEMOCRAT PROCEED
DIRECTLY DO THAT THROUGH MY
CLOSER YES PLEASE REGRESSION
FIRST AND FOREMOST A MATURE
AGAIN- I JUST WANNA SAY THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE ABLE
TO PRESENT TODAY- AND THINK THE
COMMITTEE EFFORT TO SUPPORT AND
I ALSO WANNA TAKE A MOMENT TO
SAY HOW GRATEFUL I AM TO GO TO
WORK WITHIN OUR DOLLAR EACH AND
EVERY DAY OUR DISTRICTS HAD BEEN
IMPACTED. GREATLY BY A GROWING
WILDFIRES THE DEVASTATION IS OFF
THE CHARTS IN THE SUFFERING- IT
HAS- THREE. SINCE THOUSAND
FIFTEEN IN THE STATE. IN WHAT I
FIRMLY BELIEVE IS THAT ALL THE
LOW HANGING FRUIT WITH CLIMATE
CHANGE HAS BEEN ADOPTED IN THE
STATE. AND NOW WHAT WE'RE
STARING AT IS A CRISIS IT'S
GOING TO IMPACT OUR LIVES BUT IN
PARTICULAR OUR KIDS LIVES ARE
GREAT CAN GRANDKIDS LIVES AND WE
DO NOT ACT WITH SPEED AND
URGENCY ARE THEIR LIVES WILL BE
WORSE OFF THAN OURS TODAY. SO
HERE'S WHAT I THINK IS GONNA
HAPPEN THANKS TO THE LEADERSHIP
OF PROTEIN MACHEN'S THE SENATE
IS GOING TO BE ADVANCING THE
MOST ROBUST.CLIMATE ACTION PLAN
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE HAS EVER
SEEN FOCUSING ON ISSUES OF
POLICY. THIS GOVERNOR HAS
INVESTED MORE THAN ANY OTHER
GOVERNOR IN CALIFORNIA. IN
FORESTRY AND FORESTRY MANAGEMENT
HANDS DOWN COMPARE HIS TRACK
RECORD WITH PREVIOUS AND I AM
GRATEFUL FOR GOVERNOR BROWN'S
LEADERSHIP. AND I FIRMLY BELIEVE
THAT YOU'RE GONNA SEE. MORE
MONEY IN FACT I KNOW YOU'RE
GONNA SEE MORE MONEY IN
FORESTRY. AND FIRE PREVENTION.
THIS YEAR THAN YOU DID LAST YEAR
AS BEING PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR AND- IF YOU WOULD YOU
COULD SEE SOONER MY CASKET RIGHT
NOW WITH YOUR BUDGET SEPT TWO
HE'S READY TO MOVE ON OTHER
IDEAS AND PROPOSALS AS WELL SO I
FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO SEE. ADDITIONAL DOLLARS THAT
WILL BE ADVANCE IN THE BUDGET
WORKING WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND IT WILL LEAD ON THAT
IN THE SENATE HANDS DOWN WILL BE
LEADING THE STATE WITH PROACTIVE
POLICY TO BETTER COMBAT THIS
CLIMATE CRISIS. NOW RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I'VE- FOR THE CENTER
BRIGITTE THAT ALL RIGHT. AS WE
MOVE CENTERPIECE COLOR. I AM
NUMBER TWO S. C. R. FIFTY THREE
THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED ALAN HI
. FAITH DOLLY. NOT VOTING. YEAH. IT IS A DOLLAR NOT VOTING SIDE
RIGHT- DALLY NOT LOADING THANK
YOU. ARKANSAS'S THE KNOWLEDGE I
SKINNER SKINNER I STERN STERN I
LIKE OWSKI HI NANCY I OKAY- THAT
THAT- VOTE ABOUT THE RESOLUTION
OF THE VOTES TO GET OUT PRECIADO
. SHOULD YOUR LEADERSHIP SENATOR
WHEN WE TAKE INTO A MOTION TO-
TO MURPHY CAN CHECK OUT- JUST AS
BEFORE THE FIVE TO ONE- ONE BILL
IT'S MOVED BY SENATOR GONZALES
CONSECTETUR. YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE CARD CONSENT CALENDAR
ON CONSENT CALENDARS ITEM NUMBER
ONE SP FORTY FIVE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS IN THE ORDER TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ALAN HI ALAN I
HATE. DOLLY DALLY SP FORTY FIVE
FORTY FIVE I ALI I CAN SOLACE AS
ALWAYS I SKINNER SKINNER I STERN
. STERN I Y. CASKEY. HI KELSEY I
SO. THAT IS OUT UNANIMOUSLY THAT
WE DON'T COURSE HAVE OUR VICE
CHAIR HERE WELL THANK YOU MEMBER
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE WILL HAVE
MORE HEARINGS COMING UP BUT THIS
IS A RELATIVELY SIMPLE ONE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK- AND- THIS
HEARING. IS HEREBY ADJOURNED.
BUT. THEY WILL HELP ME OUT AND
READ THAT I MEAN PEOPLE.